بعد ان صنعتهم لمهاجمه خصومها ميليشيا
الحوت تجرو نشطاء انقلبوا عليها
وتصريحات عن طلب نائب الزواج من قاصر تفجر
غضبا في الاردن ومطالبات بالاعتذار وحقيقه
مقطع اعتداء والده بكى على شاكيرا في
الشارع اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في احدث حمله من حملات قمع ميليشيا الحوتي
لكل من يعارضها حكمت محكمه حوتيه بسجن
الناشطين على منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
احمد علاوي ومصطفى مومري واحمد حجر وحمود
المصباحي الذين اعتقلتهم الميليشيا ومثلوا
امام المحاكم من يناير ووجهت لهم تهم
تقدير الامن العام والحاق الضرر بالمصلحه
العامه وتراوحت عقوبه السجن لكل منهم ما
بين سته اشهر لغايه ثلاث سنوات كما تم
تغريبهم عشره ملايين ريال ايما يعادل 4000
دولار وتم تداول انباء على ان محامي
الناشطين قد استانف الحكم الصادر بحقهم
وقال ان الحكم الصادر بحقهم وحكم جائر
وغير قانوني ومحاوله لتكميم الاصوات
المعارضه والمنتقده الاعلام الامني التابع
لميليشيا الحوثي كان نشر من ايام ما يمكن
ان نسميه مسرحيه لاعترافاتهم متابع
انا اعترف والكاميرا امامي واعترف ان به
فيديوهات طعمت الدوله في ظهرها صح
به فيديوهات استغل يعني فيديو
استغلها العدو صح يعني كيف اقول لك
احنا كنا نبث يا اخي السلبيه كنا اي شيء
سلبي نندع فيديو اي حاجه سلبيه
تواصل باحمد شاكر
وقال لي الجامعه مغلقه نشتي بالله توصل
لمصطفى
رائعه قال وصل صوتنا مشي في ديو ضخم قلت
لها على طول يا احمد
طبعا الاتفاق يعني في البدايه قلنا له
عشره الف دولار تمام هذا قبل ما اني جامعه
وانه
مغلقه اهم شيء قلت لها عشره الف الفيديو
هذا انا اخطات فيه واسات على انصار الله
في بعض الناس مستاء من انصار الله وانا
ذكرت انصار الله انا ما كنت اعمم انا
اتهمتم غلط حكايه مثلا انهم بيخرجوا
فعاليات وبيخرجوا بسيرات ويفصلوا الموظفين
هذا هذا كلام كله فاضي هذا كلامك كله فاضي
كنت اقوم بمهاجمه انصار الله بالتغريدات
يعني كنت اهاجمهم
ومش فاهم دورهم للوطن ودفاعهم على الوطن
يعني ما كنتش فاهم اي شيء الدوري الذي
بيقوموا به كنت احسبهم ان الناس عنصريين
وانهم ما يحبون الا انفسهم وان لهم دعم
خارجي وكذا
للامانه يعني فانا محرج من كل تغريده
كتبتها
لماذا قلنا مسرحيه اعترافاتهم لانه ببساطه
هؤلاء الناشطون على منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي هم ناشطون حوثيون صنعتهم
الميليشيا وجندتهم للدفاع عنها ومهاجمه كل
من يعاتها واليوم تحاكمهم وتعاقبهم بعد
انقلبوا عليها وهجموها ونشرت الاعترافات
التي شهدناها واللافت ايضا انه رغم انه
اتهمت مصطفى المومري واحمد حجر وحموده
مصباحي هي نفس التهمه وهي تقدير الامن
العام والاضرار بالمصلحه العامه لان
الاحكام ضدهم جاءت بالسجن سنه ونصف
للمومري وسنه لاحمد حجر وسته اشهر لحمود
المصباحي اما احمد علاو فتهمته الميليشيا
بنفس التهم زملائه وزادت عليها تهمه اعانه
العدو وحكمت عليه بالسجن ثلاث سنوات
ومن القاهره ينضم الينا عبد الكريم المادي
القيادي في حزب المؤتمر الشعبي العام
اليمني اهلا بك استاذ بدايه ما تعليقك على
مسرحيه الاعترافات التي شهدناها قبل قليل
لتبرير الاحكام التي صدرت بحقهم
ممسكي بالخير والمشاهد الكريم
لحقوق ايضا المشائخ في صنعاء وفي عمران
وفي حجه وفي اب وفي اكثر من منطقه ممن
خدموا ميليشيات الحوثيه وسهلوا دخولها الى
درجه انه تم اغتيال مشايخ في بيوتهم وفي
الطرقات من قبل الحوثيه وهناك من تم سحلهم
انتقاما منهم ولذلك الناشطون هؤلاء الذين
خدموا ميليشيات الحوثيه انا اعتقد انها
اضافه جديده من اضافات ميليشيات الحوثيه
الظلاميه وعبره لبقيه من يعمل مع ميليشيات
الحوثيه تحت اي مسمى كان لكن برايك لماذا
انقلبوا على الحوثيين بعد ان يعني نفذوا
اجنده الحوثيين على مدى سنوات والان لماذا
انقلبوا ضد الحوثيين
لماذا برايك هو اولا هناك
اكتسبوا شهره واسعه حقيقه الام يعني في
السوشيال ميديا وخاصه في يوتيوب وبقيه
المنصات الاخرى اكتسبوا شهره واسعه
واعتقدوا في لحظه معينه على انه ممكن
يضاعفه من يعني من منسوب هذه الشهره ويعمل
على انهم يدافعوا عن حقوق عامه ويدينوا
انتهاكات حوثيه وعلى ان الشهره ممكن ان
تحميهم من يد منشيه الحوثيه لكنهم وقعوا
في فخ انه هذه جماعه ارهابيه وجماعه
ميليشياويه عنصريه وكان الاحرى بهم النوم
ممكن ينتقلوا الى منطقه امنه منطقه محرره
الى حتى لو استدعى الامر الى اي جبهه من
جبهات الجبهات الوطنيه المواجهه لميليشيات
الحوثيه وان يسخروا سمعتهم وشهرتهم وعدد
المتابعين لهم ومن ثم يكشفوا جرائم
ميليشيات الحوث
يعني انخدعوا بمساله على انه الشهره التي
حصلوا عليها قد تكون يعني حمايه لهم
وحصانه لهم في العاصمه صنعاء وهذا ما لم
يحدث عند ميليشيات الحوثيه التي عندما
تقرر ان تقتل فهي تقتل يعني الناس حتى لو
كانوا من ضمن قيادات هذه الميليشيات كما
حصل لعبد الكريم جربان واحمد جرف الدين
وعبد الكريم الخيواني وايضا
وزير الشباب والرياضه حسن زيد السابق لدم
الاشيه الحوثيه انا اعتقد بانه ميليشيات
الحوثيه ايضا تريد ان توصل رساله وتقول
للمواطن اليمني والاعلامي والحقوقي
والسياسي انه حينما تتحدث ضد مسيره الظلام
والعنصريه والقتل سيكون مصيرك مصير هذا
وهذا وتجعل منهم عبره للبقيه لكن انا في
نقطه مهمه اعتقد انه الضريبه الدفاع عن
الوطن يجب ان تكون يعني جاهزه لكل مواطن
يمني ولا كل من يدافع عن ارضه امام عنصريه
طائفيه تحاول ان تبدد العقيده وتحاول ان
تجرف العقيده وحق المواطنه اليوم صنعاء
القديمه تحاول ان تجرفها ميليشيات الحوثيه
وتدمر اربعه اسواق وتبني مكان هذه الاسواق
حوزه طائفيه شيعيه وكذلك الامر نفسه في
منطقه عصر لذلك
الاحكام التي انا الاحكام التي صدرت بحق
المومري واحمد حجر وعلاوه والمصباحي انا
اولا كمواطن يمني وكصحافي وكاعلامي
وادينها ادينها باشد العبارات واطالب
باطلاق سراحهم كمواطنين يمنيين في الدرجه
الاولى ومن حقهم انه يعبر عن رايهم عن ما
يدور من حولهم اريد ان اسالك وهذا اخر
سؤال لي بالنسبه لنهج الذي يستخدمه
الحوثيين لتكميم الافواه
لصنع جيش الكتروني يدافع عن اجنداتهم
ويروج لها في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وعندما ينقلبون ضدها يتخلون عنه ويهاجمونه
ويعتقدونهم اريد ان اعرف منك عن هذه
المنهج للحوثيين في الجيش الالكتروني الذي
تستخدمه
المنهج يا استاذه هو انه هذه الجماعه
اساسا جماعه منغلقه تماما وعنصريه تماما
وجماعه تستخدم العنف والارهاب باوسع ما في
الكلمه من معنى لديها طبعا اجهزه معينه
استخباراتيه واجهزه امنيه وهي اساسا يعني
سيطرت على مقدرات الدوله ومؤسسات الدوله
اضافه الى ذلك لديها خبراء من حزب الله
ومن الحرس الثوري الايراني هم من يضعون
المخططات وهناك ايضا ممن تعلموا من
ميليشيات الحوثيه وتدربوا على ايدي الحرس
الثوري الايراني ورجعوا الى اليمن لكي
يعملوا ضمن هذه الخطه وعملوا جيش الكتروني
واسع جدا حتى انه في الفتره الاخيره عملوا
على انهم ينتقلوا الى منصه تويتر وهي منصه
مهمه جدا وكانت تكشف كثير من جرائمهم من
خلال حسابات يمنيه وحسابات عرب حاولوا
الان ابن جيش جيشا الكترونيا في هذه نعم
نعم وضحت الفكره شكرا لمداخلتك اعطانا
معنا عبد الكريم المادي القيادي في حزب
المؤتمر الشعبي العام اليمني شكرا لك
جادل واسع في الاردن اثارته تصريحات لقاضي
القضاه الشيخ عبد الحافظ الربطه خلال
مؤتمر صحفي كان يتكلم خلاله عن نسب وحالات
الزواج في المملكه
قلنا لهم ما في اقل من 18 سنه لو مين ما
كنت تزعل ترضى انت حر هذه البنت بنتنا
جميعا
قاد القضاه كما شاهدنا سويا تكلم عن رغبه
نائب لم يكشف عن هويته في الزواج من فتاه
قاصر تبلغ من العمر 15 عاما وعن محاوله
نائب اخر الوساطه لتزويج فتاه اخرى عمرها
16 عاما ونصف وقال انه في كلتال حالتين تم
رفض الامر من قبل دائره القضاء بسبب عدم
اتمام الفتاتين سن الثامنه عشره او السن
الزواج القانوني في الاردن هذا التصريح
اثار غضبا وجدلا واسعين في الاردن بسبب
زواج القاصرات وكيف يمكن ان يقبل نواب في
البرلمان على مثل هذا الامر المرفوض
قانونيا واخلاقيا
بعد هذا الغضب نشرت وسائل اعلام اردنيه
نقلا عن مصدر مطلع في دائره القاضي القضاه
لان النائب الذي تحدث عنه قاضي القضاه ماب
سابق والقصه قديمه لا علاقه لها بمجلس
النواب الحالي لكن رغم ذلك فالغضب لم يهدا
ووصل لقبه مجلس النواب حيث ارسل نائب زياد
العتوم خطابا الى قاضي القضاه يطالبه فيها
بالاعتذار رسميا من كل نواب ويتهمه
بالاساءه للسلطه التشريعيه وقال ان المقطع
ازعجه هو وزملائه وسال انقاذ القضاهما
لاستهداف النواب فقط وتحدث عن الحادثتين
اللتين ذكرهما رغم ان قصصا كهذه كثيره
وتعرض عليه يوميا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد انتشر في الساعات
الماضيه مقطع فيديو لوالده اللاعب الشهير
جرابكه مع شاكيرا بجانبهما ايضا والمقطع
ملايين المشاهدات نتابعه
الفيديو الذي عرضناه صوره احد المره في
مكان عام ويظهر فيه نقاش محتدم بين شاكيرا
ووالده ويبدو ان الام لم تكن راضيه عن
كلام شاكيرا وحاولت اسكاتها ووضعت يدها
على فمها حتى لكن شاكيرا بقيت تتكلم لتقوم
والده بالاشاره بسبابتها على فمها لتسقط
شاكيرا كل هذا فيما يقف بينهما متفرجا
الفيديو تم تداوله بشكل كبير وضم كثيرون
انه جديد الحقيقه انه قديم من وقت علاقه
الثنائي وسبب تداوله اليوم من جديد غير
معلوم لكن عموما الحديث عن العلاقه السيئه
بين شاكيرا ووالده ليست جديده فالاخبار عن
العلاقه السيئه التي جمعت السيده لم تتوقف
وكان دائما عنوانها انها ولن تحب شاكيرا
ولم تكن داعمه لعلاقه الثنائي وكانت
تتهمهما دائما بانشغالها بعملها واهمالها
وطفليهما
تم تداول اخبار عن مصادر اعلاميه ان والده
بيكي كانت على علم بعلاقته الجديده ولكنها
لم تخبر شاكيرا ومن ثم شاهدنا والده ووالد
بيكي علنا بصحبه ابنهما وحبيبته الجديده
فيما يشير لرضاهما عن العلاقه التوتر بين
شاكيرا ووالده بيكيه هذا كان بلغ اوجه بعض
انفصال الثنائي فراينا اخبار مدعومه بصور
ومقاطع لبناء شاكيرا جدارا فاصلا بين
منزلها في برشلونه ومنزل والده بيكي هذا
كمان سبق ذلك وضع شاكيرا لدميه ساحره على
شرفتها المطله على منزل والده بيكيه وقامت
بتشغيل اغنيتها على صوت مرتفع ومسموع
نتحدثون عن الاغنيه التي طرحتها شاكيرا من
شهرين وشغلت العالم وحققت نجاحا كبيرا
وحطمت ارقاما قياسيه وفيها تهاجم شاكيرا
بيكي وحبيبته الجديده بشكل غير مباشر
[موسيقى]
كشفت صحيفه بيبوسديل الصينيه النقابه عن
احدث عضو في فريق مذيع الاخبار لديها
والمذيعه ليست تقليديه
[موسيقى]
ربما لو لم تعلن ران انها مذيعه بالذكاء
الاصطناعي لما عرف احد فشكلها او هيئتها
ولبسها وحتى حركه الشفاه تظهرها وكانها
مذيعه حقيقيه وتقول انها تعلمت مهاراتها
من الالاف من المذيعين الاخبار حول العالم
ويمكنها تغطيه الاخبار 24 ساعه في اليوم
دون حاجه للراحه وذلك عبر تطبيق كما انها
جاهزه للاجابه على اسئله المستخدمين في
مختلف المجالات لكن في الوقت الراهن مذيعه
الذكاء الاصطناعي قادره على تقديم واجابات
حول مواضيع عامه فقط بالطبع جميعها متصقه
مع توجه الحكومه الصينيه والحزب الحاكم
اذا ان طلبت ايضا من المستخدمين ترك
تعليقاتهم على اجاباتها ورايهم في طريقه
تقديمها للاخبار واكدت لهم ان هذا
سيساعدها جدا للتطور على الدوام وطبعا ران
هي المذيعه الاولى التي يمكن ان تنشئ
محادثه معها ولكن ليست الاولى في تقديم
الاخبار ففي عام 2018 و 2019
اعلن عن اكثر من مذيع افتراضي ناطق
بالصينيه وبالانجليزيه ايضا
وبهذه المناسبه كانت هاشتاقات الام متصدره
مختلف المنصات وكالعاده جوجل ايضا احتفل
معنا وحول صفحته الرئيسيه لبطاقه معايده
لكل الامهات في العالم مثل كل عام تعود
اغاني الام في هذا اليوم لتتصدر ويلجا
اليها المستخدمون لمعايده امهاتهم ساتركم
مع مقاطع من اجمل كاسيكيات اغاني الام في
عيدها وتفاعلكم يعود ويلقاكم غدا
[موسيقى]
رحمتك
صباح الخير يا مولاتي يا ماما ياما
ياماتي
ابوس الايد وقلبي سعيد يا اول حب في حياتي
زمن
وسهرتي
وتعبت وشي
العمر ليالي
ولسه
الوقت
تحميل الهم
[موسيقى]
انا مو تسمري
وتبدي تفكري انا وتصغري
وتبات تفكري
وتسلم
يا رب
يخليكي
يا امي
يا ست الحبايبي يا حبيبي يا علي يا حبيبه
وحبيبك